Human beings are almost unique
in that they will entrain to
an external stimulus or sound.
What this means is they'll
synchronise their bodily
movements with it.
Like dancing - they'll tap their
feet or nod their heads
in time with the rhythm
of music.
In the natural world, humans
have a preferred speed, or
tempo, at which they
like to walk.
And that's a bit like music,
which also has a tempo.
But in the modern world,
everything's changing,
including music.
Live music is great, but there's
no point having a band
if you're not all playing to
the same beat, which is why
orchestras have a conductor.
For contemporary bands,
keeping the
rhythm together is important.
Even bands that play live, such
as the Gorillaz, might
use samples or loops when
they're playing.
And they use something
like a click track to
keep them in time.
[CLICK TRACK CLICKING RHYTHM]
So the problem with the backing
track is that it
doesn't change, so the drummer's
forced to listen to
that to keep them in time.
To try and solve this problem of
getting a computer sequence
to follow a drummer, the first
thing we want to do is give it
something to listen to.
So we put up microphones
on the drums.
We've got a kick drum mic
and a snare drum mic.
And we put those through
a process that's
called onset detection.
It simply says when he actually
hits that drum - [DRUM HIT]
- and that gives us event times
of when they're hit.
Then we have a click track from
the computer of where it
thinks the bar and the beat
is, and the two have to be
compared to give it
a tempo output.
What's complex is that the
drummer has a lot of
techniques that you may not
ordinarily think of here.
It's things like syncopation.
He's putting beats or humming
in unusual places.
And events can happen
early or late.
That's part of the feel of
what a drummer does.
A drummer isn't a metronome
robotically playing a pattern.
They're putting accents and
moving the time around.
So that really gives it
something complex in terms of
the rhythm.
And what I've had to do here is
try and create the best way
for the computer to understand
the information - almost to
look around the beat, within a
window, and use the timing
information it's getting to make
the best judgement it can
of what the tempo is, and
also not go wrong.
The glorious thing about live
music is the ability to vary
things according
to the audience and
to your mood.
So for example, you might want
to slow things down a little
bit - [DRUMMER PLAYING]
- or speed things up.
[DRUMMER PLAYING]
Or you could get creative.
Easy now, Dave.
[DRUMMER PLAYING]
Alan Turing was a famous
mathematician and codebreaker.
And in the '40s, he proposed
an experiment that sets the
standard for what it might be
for a machine to be called
intelligent.
This is if a person cannot
tell the difference in
conversation whether they're
talking to a machine or
talking to a person.
And here, we're going
to apply the same
principle, but to music.
We're going to ask David
if he can tell the
difference between me tapping
and controlling a tempo and
the computer controlling the
tempo by listening to him.
I'm going to give
you two options.
I'm going to flip a coin.
And if it's heads, then I'm
going to tap and control the
speed to match your drumming
of the music that you hear.
And if it's tails, then the
computer system is going to
control the speed.
Both should feel like they
respond to you, so feel free
to try and experiment.
Try and figure out which you
think it might be, and then at
the end of each piece, you
guess which control you
thought was in charge.
Yeah?
Yep.
OK.
The less able Dave is to tell
whether it's me or the
software following his beat,
the better the software is,
and the more highly it scores
on the Turing test.
I repeated the experiment
eight times - four with me doing
the tapping, and four
with the software
doing the work.
There were, actually, through
throwing this coin, there were
four times that it was the
tapper, me, and there's four
times that the machine
was controlling it.
When it was the tapper, twice
you guessed the tapper
correctly, twice you guessed
the machine.
When it was the machine in
control, you always guessed
the tapper.
In which case, I'm pretty
happy with it.
I'm happy with how it's
performed, and that really,
you can't tell the difference
on that.
And it's an interesting test.
Having music software that can
respond to human musicians is
a real breakthrough, and
could revolutionise
the future of music.
Watch this space.
If you're interested to know
more about the research or
want to try out this software,
feel free to contact me,
Andrew Robertson, at Queen Mary
University of London.
You can also visit the website
- that's b-keeper.org.
[MUSIC PLAYING]